this is not how most people choose to
spend their Friday night knocking doors
in Croydon central but with just days
until the election
Justine Miliband can't afford an evening
off but Justine insists she's enjoying
the campaign the kids know this is a
general election on and they think that
daddy's the leader of the red team so
we've been having lots of talks about
how the red team's doing the blue team
the Green Team so that's how we're we're
approaching things for the audience but
Ed Miliband's journey hasn't been a
fairy tale he's been vilified for
everything from stumbling off the stage
to eating a bacon sandwich there are
some really serious issues around this
election and then I think there's quite
a lot of I call the other side of things
sort of the name-calling the general
pallava the general ridiculousness and I
think you take it with a sense of humor
and I feel that people will make their
own minds up how about that embarrassing
story about their second kitchen both ed
and I have got a good sense of humor and
if there's one thing I've learned over
the last four years I think we both have
having a good sense of humor is
definitely good for politics
Edie of course famously took on his
brother you had to help him through that
healing process how difficult was it for
everyone they are brothers
and they have always been brothers and
they always will be and for me when he
took his decision to used Anthony doe I
would support him just as he supported
me and all the
decisions a microwave justine says she
wants to be known for more than just a
dress but being a political wife is
cosmetic even if you don't always kiss
on cue for a woman with a successful
career in law it can't be easy I
certainly don't feel I've been held back
I spend most of my time at work it's
just that people won't see that I happen
to be out on the campaign trail now but
I'm fitting in campaigning around my job
in Justine's tour of marginal seats the
next stop was South Norwood it's no
secret that Ed Miliband's approval
ratings have struggled the hope is this
working mum could help him strike a
chord with voters so huge Sky News South
London